welcome back we continue now with our
rare exclusive interview with Supreme
Court Justice Clarence Thomas in part
two of our conversation we discussed the
recent controversies over statues and
monuments in America he's loved of the
Constitution and that small Justice
Thomas exhibit finally added to the
National African American Museum there's
a controversy because the Smithsonian
Museum African American Museum for its
first year after it opened its doors
that had basically no reference to you
except a reference to the confirmation
battle did you think anything of that or
and that really might mean people who
cared about me did you know obviously
but no not really I mean I you know I
grew up at a time when I was exposed to
just wonderful range of ideas in a
segregated library in a black library
the Carnegie Library in Savannah I mean
you might read George Schuyler in the
Pittsburgh courier or you might read a
book by you know Joe Ralph Allison or
Alwyn or you might read one by Richard
Wright so you might read something about
Booker T Washington but then WB the
voice so you had this range of ideas and
I think we're getting quite comfortable
in our society limiting ideas and
exposure to ideas and maybe that's a
symptom of it I don't know
but I don't think it's good for the next
generation and the people who will be
learning I mean I think I learned a
tremendous amount in the Carnegie
Library simply from being exposed to a
range of ideas I mean why would a little
kid in Savannah Georgia be reading and
ran why I mean somebody exposed me to it
somebody made the books available
someone said it's okay for you to read
that and you should read it and learn
from where any statues torn down during
your time as a young boy in the south
did you see any
big historical monuments moved ever or
taken down well I didn't see that much
iconoclasm I think there was there was
all kinds of there were all sorts of
other problems other problems but you
know I think we in when I grew up and
where I grew up in Savannah the people I
grew up with were a different people I
mean not simpler well when you think of
people like my grandparents these were
people who had been through quite a bit
and had a calmness and a contentment
about life and they understood putting
things in context what was important
priorities what battles are you gonna
fight today what decisions you're gonna
make what decisions you're gonna make
today will result in you being able to
eat those sorts of things and the long
term that these two boys they were
raising will be educated and that they
will have good manners and go to school
and be polite to the neighbors etc I
think that today we seem to think that
everything has to be one-size-fits-all
and people can't have opinions that make
us uncomfortable or ideas that make us
uncomfortable or that we don't agree
with they would not tolerate that so in
your grandparents went through a real
segregation they went real racism real
racial hardship yes there's a plaque in
your office with a quote on it that's
attributed to your grandfather tell us
about that well actually my
grandfather's favorite saying was I mean
there were lots of opportunities in that
environment too as you could imagine to
want to say that you couldn't do certain
things and my grandfather who was raised
in part by his grandmother who was a
freed slave and raised by his uncle and
his mother died when he was this little
kid a young boy so he was raised by his
grandmother and his uncle later on well
when you would say to him you couldn't
do something he his response was always
the same
oh man can't is dead I helped bury him
old man can is dead I helped bury him
yeah and his that was his view he would
say that to you when he got you up at
4:00 in the morning to go on the farm
and and you said I can't do this I do
that old man can't is dead that is I
wish I knew your grandfather well I wish
a lot of people knew him and I wish he
was still here
so I could thank him the fact that you
raised a son and a nephew what did you
learn from that you know I think you're
raising kids it is a humbling process
and it's increasingly humbling as they
get older then the I ain't giving any
parent who's raised kids will understand
will tell you it's humbling are you
shocked
after all these years after the 60s you
were in college when'd you graduate 71
171 those are tumultuous times at Yale
at Yale and you know the law school are
you surprised at how things are still so
rancorous in the United States today
about foundational issues not not about
but just foundational issues ant them
and so forth no I'm not surprised I mean
what what binds us what do we all have
in common anymore in the I think we have
to think about that I think this is when
I was a kid even as we had laws that
held us apart there are things that we
held dear and that we all had in common
and I think we have to we always talk
about the pluribus unum
what's our aluminum now we have the
floor of us or what's the onnum then I
think it's a great country I think we
for whatever reasons have made it our
just some people have decided that the
Constitution isn't worth defending that
history isn't worth defending that the
culture and principles aren't worth
defending then you know certainly if
you're in my position they have to be
worth defending okay that's what keeps
you going that's
what energizes you that's what makes it
the endeavor all of the criticism the
the other things that's what makes it
all acceptable because what you're doing
is so important and so critical to the
things that matter so I don't know what
it is that we have we can say
instinctively we have as a country in
common it's great to see you thank you
for making some time for us today thank
you and thank you and good luck in with
your new show thank you so much justice
it's it's easier than clerking for you
okay just teasing